Welcome guys to another spreadsheet class.
And in this one, what we're going to do is
build on the previous video where Anton
talked about setting stops and targets for
positions using distribution of returns
and average true range percentage
analyses.
So the majority of this video is going to
involve teaching you how to build a
distribution of returns analysis and also
an average true range percentage analysis
in Excel,
so that you can then estimate suitable
stops and targets for assets that you're
looking to trade.
And we're going to start off by building a
distribution of returns analysis from
scratch.
And then after that, we're going to move
over to using some templates to conduct
the rest of the analysis, which is a much
faster method since a lot of the work is
actually automated.
And these templates will, of course, be
available to you in the downloads folder
for this video.
And we have one spreadsheet template for
distribution of returns or DOR analysis
and one for an average true range
percentage or ATRP analysis.
Now, I'll show you how to use those
templates properly later in the video.
And I'm going to do that by using real
examples to calculate potential stops and
targets for individual assets in a similar
way to how Anton did it in the previous
video.
We're also going to cover a short example
of how you can create stops and targets
for spreads as well.
Now, as you guys know, creating stops and
targets is an important aspect of
preventative risk management.
And that helps us achieve better
performance as traders.
But it isn't the only preventative risk
management technique available.
And I'm going to talk about some others
towards the end of the video, which are
namely setting portfolio limits on things
like gross exposure, cash net exposure and
beta adjusted net exposures.
The reason why we employ all of these PRM
measures is so that we achieve better
trading performance, as I said.
And there are a number of ways we can
measure our performance, which
incidentally, you will hear me talk about
again in a few videos time.
But the ones I want to mention now are R
score targets and win loss rate targets.
Now, you've heard about R scores before
from previous presentations.
And this is basically just a ratio of
dollar profits to dollar losses from your
realized P&L.
And that is your your closed trades in
your portfolio.
A good target to hit for R scores is about
one point five or higher.
And a great R score is typically around
two or above.
Your win loss rate is fairly
self-explanatory.
That is just the percentage of winning
versus losing trades that you make, again,
based on your realized P&L or closed
trades in your account.
And a good win loss ratio is achieving
something like 60 percent profitable
trades and 40 percent loss making trades.
Equally 55-45 as a ratio is OK.
And 65-35 is really, really good over the
long term.
So in order to try and hit those targets,
we use PRM techniques like stops and
targets on individual trades.
But also we set various portfolio limits
as well.
For example, portfolio gross exposure
limits should be set based on a multiple
of the net cash deposit or margin in our
brokerage accounts.
Now, depending on where you are in the
world and what assets you're trading,
those limits might change.
And I'm going to talk about that more
later.
But if you're based in the US trading US
stocks, that limit is legally enforced by
brokers and capped at two times leverage.
However, if you're in other parts of the
world and have access to CFD instruments,
then you'll be able to attain much higher
leverage.
And so in that case, you need to impose
limits on yourself, which probably should
be around four times leverage.
Anything above that kind of starts to
involve much too much risk.
Limits should also be set for portfolio
beta adjusted net exposure and also cash
net exposure, as I talked about back in
video 20.
And these limits might range between plus
and minus 30% for beta and plus and minus
50% for cash net exposure.
And again, I'm going to talk about these
limits towards the end of the video.
Now, as I said, we're going to start this
video by conducting the distribution of
returns and average true range percentage
analyses for the purposes of generating
stops and targets.
And I do realize that we've already
covered distributions quite a bit in this
series.
So some of this material is going to feel
very familiar.
And on top of that, for those of you that
have done the IPLT course, the ATRP
analysis is also going to feel quite
familiar as well.
But where we are covering kind of
completely new ground here is applying
these two volatility analyses for the
purposes of creating stops and targets for
our positions.
So there will be something new for
everyone in this video, but also for many
of you, there will be parts that serve as
some solid revision of various concepts.
OK, so with that being said, let's get
started.
Now, for the purposes of our volatility
analyses in this video, we're going to
assume that we've done all of our
fundamental work to come up with a couple
of solid stock ideas.
And we're also going to assume that the
timing is in place for those ideas.
So all that we want to do now is figure
out what reasonable stops and targets
should be for our positions, given their
historical volatility.
And the trades that we're going to look at
as examples here in this video are long
ZNGA, so that's Zinger, and short ALGN,
that's Align Technologies.
And to begin with, I'm just going to use a
distribution of returns analysis to come
up with some stops and targets for these
stocks.
And then I'll move on to an average true
range percentage analysis later.
So let's look at Zinger stock first, and
the first step here is going to be
obtaining the price data that we need to
in order to create our analysis.
And I'm going to find price data for this
stock on Yahoo Finance.
Now the URL for Yahoo Finance is just
finance.yahoo.com.
So that's the website I'm going to
navigate to.
And then from there to find price data on
Zinger, the ticker is ZNGA, remember, I'm
just going to type that ticker into the
search bar at the top here, and then click
Zinger from the drop down menu.
That takes me to the stock page for that
stock.
And then from there, we're going to go to
the historical data tab.
And in this page, what we want to do is
choose the variables of the historical
data that we want to look at and then
download.
So in this case, I want to basically look
up the entire price history that we have
available on Yahoo Finance for this stock.
To do that, I'm just going to select this
time period variable here and then select
max.
And I'm also going to choose to display
and download those prices on a monthly
frequency.
So rather than daily here, I'm just going
to click that drop down and then select
monthly.
From there, I'm then going to click apply,
which will apply those variables that
we've just chosen to this data set.
And then I'm going to click on download.
Now, for me, when I click download there
on Yahoo Finance, it basically downloads
as a CSV file, which can be opened in
Excel as it will for you as well.
But depending on what your operating
system is and what web browser you're
using, you will need to take different
steps in order to open the file.
But for me, as you can see here, there's a
shortcut provided by Google Chrome.
I'm using Windows with Google Chrome, by
the way.
So I can just click on that file shortcut
there to open that price data in Excel.
So with the price data open in Excel for
this stock, there's a couple of things
that I want to address and make changes
to.
Firstly, you can see that the dates in
column A are currently showing as hash
symbols.
And that's just because the column width
isn't large enough to display the dates
properly.
So I'm just going to expand the column
width there so we can see the data more
easily.
Secondly, now we can see those dates in
column A, you'll notice that their format
is the day, followed by the month,
followed by the year.
And that might look odd to you if you're
based in the US or elsewhere.
But here in the UK, that is how we format
our dates.
That being said, to make things a little
bit clearer, I'm just going to change the
format of those dates.
And then selecting format cells and
choosing the custom category in the number
tab,
and then creating a format, a custom
format by typing over the type box here
with DD-MMM-YY.
And once I press OK there, you'll see that
that makes dates a little bit easier to
read and less ambiguous, irrelevant of
what kind of geography you're in.
Now, there's a few more steps here that I
want to take before starting to run some
calculations.
And at this stage, I just want to
highlight to you guys that I will be going
quite fast through some of this Excel work
because you guys should have seen most, if
not all of the techniques I'm going to use
in this video in previous videos in the
video series.
However, if you are unsure at any point,
don't panic.
Just pause the video and use Google to
find the answers.
It should be pretty easy given you've got
the video in front of you as well to work
from.
OK, so for a distribution of returns
analysis, we don't actually need the
volume data in column G.
So I'm just going to delete that straight
away.
And next, as I've said in other videos,
it's common practice in the finance
industry to run time series in descending
order.
And what that means is basically sorting
the price data we have here so that the
most recent data is at the top of the
sheet.
To do that, we just add a filter to the
data by selecting a column title and then
going to data on the ribbon, followed by
filter.
And then we can select the filter menu in
column A.
That's our date column and just choose to
sort that data from newest to oldest.
Finally, I think before going any further,
let's just rename this sheet that we're
working as well, just to something more
appropriate.
So I'm going to right click the sheet name
down here and just rename it to ZNGA
monthly DOR, for example.
So now we've prepared the data, we can
move on to the second step, which is
checking the data for any errors and
running our initial returns calculations.
Now, sometimes when you download data from
Yahoo Finance or other sources, you'll
find that the most recent data point shows
an incomplete period.
So, for example, here we might have seen
the difference between the most recent two
rows of price data didn't actually account
for a full month.
If something like that happens, what
you'll need to do is remove the latest
data entry because it's essential that our
prices are split evenly through time.
And as you can see here, that's what we
have.
The prices are displayed on the first of
every month running back through history.
So fortunately, everything looks good at
this point and we can move on to running
some calculations.
Now, when doing a distribution of returns
analysis for the purpose of generating
stops and targets,
it's useful to run a dual distribution
analysis whereby we look at both close to
close monthly returns and also high to low
percentage differences.
So with that being said, in column G, what
we're going to do now is calculate close
to close monthly returns.
And in column H, we'll compute high to low
monthly returns.
So in column G, I'm going to head the
column C-C returns.
And in the cells below, I'm just going to
calculate the returns for each month on a
close to close price basis.
So starting in cell two, the formula for
F2, so the current close price divided by
F3, the previous close price minus one.
And that is just a simple percentage
change formula from one period to the next
that you guys should all be familiar with.
Now, after typing that in, the formula can
be copied down to the end of the data set
by using the auto fill shortcut.
So that is just double clicking the little
green box in the bottom right of the
formula cell that we just created.
And just remember that whenever you do
auto fill a formula down or across, you
need to check the data at the end of the
series.
So here, for example, we if we scroll down
to the bottom of the data set, you'll see
that there is a div zero error in the
final cell.
And that just occurs because the formula
that we're using is trying to reference
price data that doesn't exist.
So it's trying to reference price data in
the cell below our final price data.
So knowing that we can just remove that
formula or delete the cell and move on to
the next column.
As I said, the next column is our high to
low returns.
And so I'm just going to title that column
H hyphen L returns at the formula for this
column.
It's just going to calculate the
percentage change from the low price
during a given period or month in this
case to the high price.
So the formula that I'm going to type into
cell H two here is equals C two divided by
D two minus one.
OK, obviously, after we put that in, we
can also copy that formula down to the end
of the series and check it.
And as you can see, we don't have any
errors here, so that's fine.
So that's our return calculations done.
And before we move on, let's just quickly
change some formatting there.
Firstly, I'm going to make the column
titles bold.
And then also let's change the format of
these returns columns so that they're
displayed as percentages to three decimal
places,
which is done simply by selecting the
columns and right clicking in the
selection, followed by choosing the
percentage category and overwriting the
specified decimal places to a value of
three.
So now that we have our returns
calculations done and everything formatted
to this point, the next step is to
calculate our histogram tables and charts,
which essentially tell you how many data
points lie within specific intervals for
both the close to close data and the high
to low data as well.
Now, in this video, I'm only going to walk
you through building the close to close
analysis since the steps required for the
high to low analysis is basically all the
same.
And you guys will be able to practice that
yourselves.
Also, remember that later in the video,
I'm going to show you how to use a
template file to speed all of this stuff
up.
And in there, we will be looking at both
close to close and high to low analysis.
OK, so at this stage, you've already seen
these distribution analyses a number of
times in this series.
So I won't go into too much detail here.
But as a very quick reminder, they're
useful to us because they allow us to
visually assess the empirical probability
of various ranges of values occurring.
So in this case, we're looking at stock
returns.
And so we can learn about how an asset has
behaved in the past, its volatility and
hence both the risk and opportunity in
trading that asset over the timeframe that
we're analyzing.
That's what we talked about in the IPLT
course.
Here, though, what we're going to do is
use that same analysis with the end goal
of generating suitable stops and targets
for a stock position.
So the first thing that we need to do when
creating some histogram data is to define
the intervals that we want to count the
data within.
Now, there's no hard and fast rules for
creating creating exact histogram
intervals.
But two things to make sure of are firstly
that the intervals encompass the vast
majority of data, meaning the vast
majority of our close to close returns.
And secondly, that the intervals are
evenly spaced.
Now, in this example, I'm going to choose
to start my intervals at minus 25% or
minus 0.25 in decimal format and increase
that value incrementally by 5% until we
get to a value of plus 25% or plus 0.25.
So to do that, in cell J3, I'm just going
to title this column intervals and then in
the cells below from J4 to J14, I'm going
to write in the intervals I just outlined.
So starting with a value of minus 0.25 in
cell J3 and increasing that interval by
0.05, that's 5%, until we reach a
finishing value of plus 0.25 in cell J14.
So with those intervals defined, we can
then use Excel's data analysis tool to
count the number of data points, that is
monthly returns, that lie within those
intervals that we've just created.
And to access Excel's data analysis tool
pack, you can go to data on the ribbon and
then select the data analysis button on
the right hand side.
Now, if you don't see that button, then it
probably means that you don't have the
add-in installed.
And if that's the case, don't worry, you
can install it really easily just by going
to file, then options, then add-ins.
Choose Excel add-ins and then make sure
that both the analysis tool pack and
analysis tool pack VBA checkboxes are
ticked before pressing OK on the dialog
box.
And when you do that, you'll then see the
data analysis button appear on the right
hand side.
So when clicking on the data analysis
button, we are presented with a number of
analysis tools to choose from.
And at this stage, we want to choose the
one that says histogram.
And once we select that and press OK,
you'll see another dialog box appear,
which requires various user inputs.
The first one is the input range.
That's fairly easy. It's just the range of
close to close returns that we see in
column G.
So we can just put the cursor in that box
and then select all of that data.
The next one is the bin range.
Now, the bin range is just another name
for our intervals.
So in that box, you can just select cells
J4 to J14, which are the intervals that we
just created.
And finally, we need to choose an output
range.
And to do that, I'm just going to select
the output range option and choose cell K3
and then press OK.
Now, as you can see here, that then writes
two more columns of data into our Excel
sheet.
The first is a repeat of our intervals in
column K.
And that column is called bin.
And the next one is called frequency in
column L.
And those values are actually counts of
the number of close to close returns that
have values that lie between the interval
ranges that we have created.
Now, it's not actually clear at this stage
what ranges the analysis tool is actually
using.
So let me explain that to you now.
The first value in cell L4 just counts the
number of monthly returns that have a
value of less than minus 0.25.
The cell below counts the number of
monthly returns that have a value that
lies between minus 0.25 and minus 0.2, so
minus 25% to minus 20%.
The cell below that counts the number of
monthly returns that have a value that
lies between minus 0.2 and minus 0.15 and
so on.
All the way until we get to the final
cell, cell L15, which counts the number of
monthly returns that have a value of
greater than 0.25, which is our maximum
interval.
Now, I know those ranges aren't very
obvious based on just the numbers that we
see here.
So in the next column, what I suggest we
do is write in some text that are clearer.
And then in cell M4, I'm just going to
type in the range that the count in cell
L4.
So that's going to be less than minus 25%.
In the cell below that, the next range is
between minus 25% and minus 20% and so on.
So bear with me a moment here while I type
in all of those text ranges we need just
to make this data a little bit clearer.
Okay, at this stage, I think it's a good
time to step away from this histogram
table just so that we can create some
summary statistics for this data.
For example, it'd be useful to have some
values for centrality and also volatility
amongst some other metrics as well.
And a good tool that Excel has to generate
these statistics quickly is the
descriptive statistics tool with the data
analysis tool pack.
So just as with the histogram analysis
tool, we find that by clicking on the data
analysis button within the data tab on the
ribbon.
But this time we're going to navigate to
descriptive statistics rather than
histogram.
Once that's selected, all we need to do
here is enter the input range we're using
again.
So that's our monthly close to close
returns in column G and then check the box
called summary statistics.
And this time I'm going to choose an
output for this data which is going to be
cell J17.
From there, we can see a whole bunch of
summary statistics have been populated in
the sheet.
Now, I'm not going to go through these in
any detail because we've been through all
of this stuff before in the money supply
video.
And you should also be familiar with it
all from the basic statistics PDF in video
three as well.
Instead, all I'm going to do here is just
tidy things up a little bit by increasing
the column widths so that we can see the
data more easily.
And renaming the title in cell J17 to
something like descriptive statistics.
And then also reformatting some of these
numbers to percentages or just numbers
with less decimal places depending on
what's appropriate statistic.
Now, despite going through this step for
creating some summary statistics, we don't
actually need them particularly for
figuring out our stops and targets.
However, I did want to make sure that we
covered that step just so that you know
how to generate those statistics quickly
in case you forgot from our previous
videos.
And when you're doing something like a
volatility analysis, it will help you kind
of assess the risk and opportunity in an
asset.
OK, so with that little descriptive
statistics detour out of the way, let's
get back to the histogram table that we
were creating.
So in column L, we have our frequency data
that counts the absolute number of data
points that fall within certain ranges.
However, what would be more useful to us
than the absolute values is if we had that
same data displayed as a percentage of the
total count.
So for example, we know that two
observations of monthly returns have
values below minus 25%, but it would be
nice to know what is that value as a
percentage of the entire data set.
Well, in the adjacent range.
So to begin with here, the percentage and
then that in cell 4, I'm going to create a
frequency count as divided by K31.
And that is just the count for the
adjacent range divided by the total count
in cell K31.
And that cell reference is fixed so that
we can copy the formula down to all the
rest of the columns.
Oh, sorry, all the rest of the cells in
the column.
So with that formula copied down, we have
the values that we need.
Let me quickly reformat these cells to
display themselves as a percentage to two
decimal places now.
And then just as a reminder, with this
data, it lets us say things like,
historically speaking, in this example, on
2.52% of occasions, the stock has returned
between minus 20% and minus 15% on a
monthly basis.
And from that sort of analysis, we can
then choose to extrapolate those
probabilities to the future.
Now, unfortunately, the real future
probabilities are likely to be different,
but using historical data, as I've said in
previous videos, is one of the best guides
that we have.
So moving on to the next column now, which
is the cumulative frequency column.
This data is just going to sum up the
probabilities for each range seen in
column N on an additive basis, starting
from the lowest range that we have.
Now, I'm going to start by titling this
column C U M U frequency percentage.
And then the first calculation in cell O4
is just going to be equal to cell N4.
So that's just the lowest frequency
percentage range that we have.
But in the cell below that, we want to
make sure that we add the probability for
the new range to the cumulative
probability that we have so far.
So the formula there will be equals N5
plus O4.
And then we can copy that formula down.
Now, what this data allows us to say is
things like, for example, here we've got
49.58% of the return.
That has a value of 0% or below.
And 89% of the returns data has a value of
15% or below.
That's plus 15% or below.
We can also turn these values on the head.
So for example, we can say that if 89% of
returns have a value of 15% or below, that
also then means that 11% of the data has
values of above 15%.
So these two frequency percentage columns
here, or probability columns, if you like,
are very useful for helping us generate
stops and targets.
And those are the columns that you guys
will have already basically seen and
you'll recognize from Anton's presentation
previously.
And we're going to go into a bit more
detail on these later in the video.
So with the histogram table completed, the
next stage we're going to tackle is all
about presentation.
And at the moment, the data that we've got
here looks a bit dry and isn't really
readable.
So we're going to change all of that by
improving the formatting of the cells that
we have and also create a histogram chart
so that we can visually analyze our data a
bit more easily.
Now, I'm not going to talk through all of
the changes that I'm making here because
I'm sure that you guys know how to format
your data and charts by now.
But basically, as you can see, I'm just
adding a few borders and then making our
column titles bold.
Once that's done, we should move on to
making a chart and we want that chart to
basically display our frequency percentage
column of data in the histogram table so
that we can kind of visually interpret
that data a little bit more easily.
Now, to do that, I'm just going to go to
select a blank cell beside the descriptive
statistics table and then go to insert on
the ribbon, followed by 2D column chart.
Then to add data to that chart, I'm just
going to right click inside the chart area
and go to select data.
And from there, I'm just going to choose
to add a series.
And the series name will just be the
frequency percent title and the series
values will be the range covering all of
the related data.
So from cells N4 to N15.
Next, what I'm going to do is add some
suitable labels.
The label tells us what the ranges these
frequency percentage values actually refer
to.
And this is where the text range column
that we created earlier comes into play.
So to do that, I'm going to select edit
horizontal axis labels and then choose the
axis label range, which is just M4 to cell
M15.
All right. So that's it really for our
chart.
It doesn't actually tell us anything new,
but what it does do is give us a visual
aid to understand what the distribution of
returns looks like based on the frequency
percentage data that we calculated
earlier.
Now, I'm not going to go into too much
detail here with formatting this chart.
But by all means, when you guys do this
yourselves, you can go ahead and tidy it
up a little bit.
Whether you want to add some axis labels
or whatever you want to do, that's up to
you.
But for now, we're just going to move on
to the next step.
So as far as building the analysis that's
most important for creating good stops and
targets, we're actually pretty much done
here, at least with the close to close
data.
And as I said, we're going to be looking
at the high to low data when we move over
to the template file.
That being said, a few more tables go into
further detail regarding volatility
analysis.
But they aren't actually necessary purely
for the purposes of creating stops and
targets.
So I'm going to skip building those from
scratch at this point and just talk about
them briefly when we move over to the
template file.
Now, as I said, having done the histogram
table and chart, we've completed the
majority of work required for creating
stops and targets.
But I do want to show you how you can go
the extra mile here and improve your
analysis slightly by looking at a full
percentile analysis as well.
Now, ultimately, this next part will show
a very similar thing to the histogram
data.
But it will go into a little bit more
detail since instead of considering broad
ranges of data to count within,
we can actually consider what values of
returns correspond to every single
percentile in the distribution if we
wanted to.
Now, you guys might remember this stuff
from the money supply video earlier in the
series.
But I'm also going to show you again here
just as a reminder.
So as a reminder, percentiles are a
statistical measure indicating the value
below which a given percentage of
observations lie.
So for example, the 50th percentile will
be below which 50% of all returns lie,
which incidentally is also known as the
median value.
Equally, the 75th percentile is the
returns value below which 75% of the data
lies and so on.
This way of looking at the data is
basically the same as the cumulative
frequency data that we calculated
previously,
except that because we aren't working from
ranges of returns defined by intervals in
a histogram,
we can get a little bit more granular and
just compute any percentile that we wish.
And that is why I said previously that
this percentile analysis can add a little
bit more detail.
So let's create this percentile analysis
table now at the bottom here then.
And I'm going to start by defining all the
percentage ranks that we want to work out
percentile scores for,
meaning related returns values.
So in cell J33 to J47, I'm going to type
in percentiles from 1% to 15%.
And those values are going to
incrementally increase by 1% in each cell.
And then in cells L33 to 47, I'm going to
type in percentiles from 1% to 15%.
I'm going to incrementally increase the
percentiles by 5% starting from 20% in L33
and finishing at 80% in L45.
And then in cells N33 to N47, I'm going to
incrementally increase the percentiles by
1% again,
starting from 85% and finishing at 99%.
Next, in the adjacent cells to all of
these ranks, we're going to work out the
percentiles themselves.
So starting in cell K33, the formula will
just be equals percentile.inc.
That's our function, Excel function that
we're going to use.
Open brackets, column G, and that's a
fixed reference, comma, cell J33, and
close brackets.
Now, this formula works out the value of
returns where less than or equal to 1% of
the data lies.
So notice with the formula that we're
referencing column G, since that's where
all of our returns data is.
And cell J33 as well, because that is the
percent rank that we're working out the
percentile value for.
Now, it's important to fix the reference
for column G, as I said, so that we can
copy across this formula easily in a few
moments time.
So from here, we can just copy the formula
down to the next cell,
checking out the value of returns where
less than or equal to 2% of the data lies.
And if we kind of continue with that
logic, we can copy the formula all the way
down to cell K47 now.
And then to work out the sort of values
for other percentage ranks, we can just
copy across the formula that we created in
cell K33 into cells M43 and O43 and auto
fill them down for all the percentage
ranks that we have.
Finally, to finish off this table, I'm
just going to add some outside borders to
the three sections here.
So the three sections are from cell ranges
J33 to K47, from L33 to M47 and from N33
to O47.
And then I'm also going to reformat all
the percentiles that we've calculated.
So they're displayed as percentages to two
decimal places as well.
Okay, guys, so now we've done all of that
work to build out a distribution of
returns.
Hopefully that was just kind of a reminder
for you guys, really.
Let's move over to a template file that
contains all the same analysis we just
built, but also includes a high to low
returns distribution as well,
which as you can see here is on the right
hand side.
Now, as I said previously, you also notice
a couple of extra tables that weren't
covered in the previous section, and those
are these ones here.
So the analysis of positive and negative
returns and also the standard deviation
band analysis.
Now, like I indicated at the time, these
tables aren't really that important for
generating stops and targets, which is why
I didn't cover them.
But they do provide some extra detail to
help you understand the volatility and
hence risk and opportunity of trading the
asset that you're looking at.
Now, I'm not going to go into any more
analytical detail on that because it was
covered extensively in the IPLT course.
And I also talked about it a bit in the
money supply video earlier in the series
as well.
So you guys can go back and check that if
you need to.
That being said, I did want to make sure
we included it in the template file just
so that you have it and you can use it if
you wish.
So let's have a look at this template
properly now.
And as you can see, I've already entered
all of the price data we used previously
for our ZNGA idea.
And now we can start using that data to
help us come up with a sensible stop and
target.
Now, a quick note here, guys, I'm going to
go through how to update this template
file and import new prices shortly using
our align technology short example.
But what I want to do first is get into
the analysis of choosing a suitable stop
and target for our long ZNGA idea first.
Also, regarding the data that you can see
here, it is all the same as in the sheet
that I just manually built.
It just looks slightly different because
different intervals were used for the
histogram.
But I assure you that the underlying data
is all the same.
So the methodical way to go about this is
firstly to figure out a stop value that
means we're unlikely to get stopped out
too easily based on the empirical data
that we have here.
So for example, if we look at the
histogram data at the top of the sheet, we
can see that in the cumulative frequency
data column that around 25% of the time
ZNGA stock has returned minus 6.86% or
less.
So that means conversely that 75% returned
more than minus 6.86%.
If we get our stop loss at 7% and I say 7%
because it's 6.86 rounded to the nearest
whole number, then we would have about a
75% chance of not being stopped out based
on the empirical data that we have here.
And that is perhaps a little tight for a
stop loss, but let's go with it now as a
starting point.
Realistically, we probably want somewhere
between a 70% to 85% chance of not being
stopped out based on the historical data.
Now, 7% is in that range for this stock,
but it is at the tight end of that range.
So given a stop loss of 7%, what does that
make our target?
Well, as Anton has talked about in the
previous presentation, our target should
be at least three times our stop on the
positive side,
which means that we're basically trying to
construct the trade with a 1 to 3 risk
reward ratio and a target R score of 3.
So that means a 7% stop loss would equate
to a 21% target.
Next, before we accept those values, we
need to try and understand what the
likelihood is of achieving our target.
So basically, what is our realistic
opportunity here?
Well, if we have a look back to the
histogram table, we can see that only in
about 4.2% of cases has the stock had a
monthly return of greater than 22%.
And that might not sound great, but there
are a few things to consider here.
Firstly, we're only looking at monthly
data here.
So to achieve our target of 21% over three
months would be considerably more likely
than over one month.
For example, achieving around a sort of 7%
or more return each month has around a 23%
probability per month.
Secondly, at the moment, we have only
considered close to close data.
Within each month, the high to low range
will, of course, be larger than our close
to close data.
And if we look at the high to low data we
have here, we can see that in around 97.5%
of occurrences, the high to low range is
greater than 7.56%.
Now, that obviously includes months where
the stock traded down, but it still shows
a really decent high to low volatility.
Thirdly, we should expect that given our
fundamental analysis, we're moving these
percentage probabilities slightly in our
favor, meaning it's actually slightly more
likely that the stock achieves returns in
the direction we want, subject to the
quality of our fundamental analysis, of
course.
Now, of course, we can't count on that,
but it is something to bear in mind.
So with the high to low returns
distribution showing us that the high low
volatility range is almost certain to be
over 7% on a monthly basis, what can we
actually take from that?
Well, it means that we'll probably know if
we're wrong quite quickly if the stock has
a down month, and we'll probably be
stopped out very quickly.
Equally, though, it also means that
there's ample opportunity for things to go
right as well.
If we've done our fundamental and
technical work well, there is enough
volatility in the stock to achieve our
target.
Now, I said a few moments ago that 7%
might be a bit tight as a stop loss, given
there's a 25% chance being stopped out on
a monthly basis to close prices.
And that's without any consideration of
intramonth moves.
We've also seen with the high to low data
that 7% price differences from low to high
occur very frequently.
Given that, we might also consider
refining our stops and targets slightly,
and we can do that using the percentile
tables quite easily.
And one way to look at this is simply by
saying that you want to have a stop that
represents only a certain percent chance
of being triggered on a close to close
basis.
So rather than a 25% chance, for example,
what about a 20% chance or a 15% chance?
If we look at our percentiles for the
close to close data, we can look across
from the various percentage ranks and see
what percentile value that corresponds to.
So, for example, if you want a stop that
historically would have been triggered
about 15% of times on a close to close
basis,
then you can look across from the 15th
percentage rank and see a stop return of
minus 10.14%.
Equally, for a stop, we can see that the
stop return would be minus 8.22%.
Now, of course, increasing the size of the
stops means increasing the size of the
target on the other side, given our 1 to 3
ratio.
So when you do this, there's basically two
things to consider.
Firstly, you need to make sure that
there's enough room for the stock to move
without being stopped out too easily.
And secondly, you need to make sure
there's enough volatility in the stock to
reach your target, given the historical
data.
Now, balancing those two items should get
you somewhere near an answer.
And then beyond that, it kind of becomes a
discretionary decision and your sort of
risk appetite may play a part as well.
Now, at this stage, you might also want to
consider some technicals when setting
stops and targets as well.
But you do need to be a little bit careful
with that.
You can only kind of use that after you've
determined a suitable range as defined by
historical volatility.
Now, you've got to remember that
volatility is the driving factor and the
most important consideration for setting
stops and targets.
So let's say we've chosen to go with an 8%
stop and a 24% ZNGA analysis.
The current price for the stock on the
22nd of December 2021 is 6.38.
And if we enter those details into the
orange cells at the bottom of this
template file, then you will see that it
then calculates what the price stop and
target values are based on those inputs
that we entered.
So in this example here, the stop loss
should be set at 5.87 and the target
should be $7.91.
OK, so that's some analysis done now for
our long ZNGA position.
Let's have a look now at our Align
technology short.
And by the way, guys, I've said this
before, but I'll say it again.
Any stocks that I'm talking about here are
just examples.
Don't be stupid and try to kind of use
these ideas in your portfolio because
there's no fundamental work that's gone
into them.
And by the time you watch this video,
everything's going to have changed anyway.
All right.
So to generate stops and targets for Align
technologies, I'm just going to use this
template file again.
And by doing so, you guys are going to see
how easy it is to do this analysis quickly
and successfully for any stock that you
wish.
So whenever you're using this template
with new or updated data, the first step
is to remove the old stale data that we
already have here.
And since we want to move on to
calculating stops and targets for Align
technologies, we no longer need the ZNGA
data in this file.
So to clear out all of that, you just need
to select all of the data in columns A to
F and then press delete on the keyboard
and that will clear the contents of those
cells.
After that, you will see that almost all
the formulas in this sheet return error
values.
You don't need to worry about that.
It's just because there's no new data to
work with in the file yet.
So next, what we want to do is delete our
stop and target inputs in the orange cells
in cells K, 59, 60 and 62.
And after that, the spreadsheet is ready
to have new data imported into it.
So this is the point at which we head over
to Yahoo Finance again and obtain monthly
price data, this time for Align
Technologies.
So let's see the Yahoo Finance website and
navigating to the Align Technologies stock
page by typing in the ticker ALGN into the
search bar at the top and then selecting
the historical data tab once we're on the
Align Technologies stock page.
From here, we want to choose the maximum
time period possible again.
And also we want to make sure that the
frequency of data is set to monthly.
After that, you can just click apply and
download.
And then with the data downloaded, you
just need to navigate to the downloaded
file and open it.
And once it's open, you can see here we
need to take a few of the same steps that
we did before, which is expand the column
width so that you can actually see the
data and also sort that data from newest
to oldest.
So in descending order, you can do that by
clicking any one of the column titles and
then going to data on the ribbon and
choosing filter.
And after that, we use the date filter to
sort the data.
Now, here you can see what I was talking
about before when I said sometimes when
you download price data, it can show
prices for incomplete periods.
So what we need to do here is delete the
most recent row since it doesn't represent
a full month of data.
And once that's done, we can copy columns
A to F and paste them as values into
columns A to F in the template file.
To paste the data as values, just right
click on column A and choose the one, two,
three clipboard option from the paste
options.
And the reason why I'm telling you to
paste the data as values is just so that
we can keep all the formatting as it was
in the template file in those columns,
which just makes it look a bit neater.
Now, at this stage, then you might see
that all the calculation cells update
properly and there's no longer any errors.
However, we aren't quite done yet.
Before moving on to some analysis, we need
to make sure that our returns columns are
updated properly.
Remember, we've imported a completely
different set of data that will be a
different length to the prior one in the
file.
And so the returns formulas need to be
adjusted so that they're the same length
as the new series.
To do that, just navigate to the bottom of
those columns of data and see whether the
formulas need to be either deleted or auto
filled down to match the raw price data
length.
In this case, we can see that the raw data
is a longer data set than our formulas are
currently.
So we need to auto fill these formulas
down to the end of the data.
And once that's done, remember to delete
the final formula in column G, since it's
always going to return an error for the
reasons I mentioned earlier.
And now that that's done, we're ready to
move on to some analysis.
So if we take a look at the data for
aligned technologies quickly, it looks
like it's more volatile at first sight
than Zinger stock was since the range of
monthly returns is a lot wider.
That being said, though, we do have to
bear in mind that the data set is a lot
longer and therefore it's been traded
through more economically volatile
periods, such as the 2008 crisis, for
example.
Now, that's just something we want to take
a mental note of. We don't want to adjust
our data set.
We want to use the full data set since it
improves the statistical significance of
our analysis.
So let's have a look at what we have here.
If we start with the close to close
histogram, we can see that there's about
an 83.6% chance of the stock returning up
to 14.33% in a monthly period.
Remember that we're assuming a short
fundamental thesis for this stock.
And so that means we can view those
figures the other way around, meaning
there's a 16.4% probability.
That's 100% minus 83.6%.
And there's a 16.4% probability of being
stopped out using a 14.33% stop based on
the empirical data that we have.
Now, on the face of it, that seems like
quite a wide stop.
And if you think about the sort of
probabilistic range that we like to see
for stops,
we typically want a 70 to 85% chance of
not being stopped out based on the
historical close to close data.
So in this case, a 14.33% stop is right at
the top end of that.
For now, though, let's just assume that
we're going to go with that 14% stop for
this stock and see what everything looks
like in terms of a target.
Now, remember, our target is always based
around a three times multiple of our stop.
And so if we say our stop is 14%, then our
target should be 42%.
Based on our close to close data, there's
only a 0.8% chance that Align Technologies
has a return of less than minus 40.53% in
a month.
So this already feels like it's much too
unlikely.
But even if we ignore those probabilities
for a moment and just use some common
sense,
does it really sound like it's a good idea
to set an initial soft target that can
only really be hit if the stock halves?
It just doesn't really sound reasonable.
So let's skip over to the percentile
analysis now just to see if we can find
something that works a bit better with the
extra detail that we have here.
Something that sticks out straight away
here is the huge jumps in percentile
values from the 85th percentage rank to
the 80th and then to the 75th.
And remember, we're looking at a short
here.
So for a stop that's only going to be
triggered 25% of the time historically
based on monthly close to close data,
we need to look at the 75th percentage
rank, not the 25th.
So let's consider creating a stop around
the 75th percentile then where the return
value is about 10%.
That would mean that our target is about
30% and if we look at the percentile table
to find where minus 30% lies,
it's somewhere between 2 and 3 in terms of
percentage rank.
That means that historically there's only
been somewhere between 2 and 3% of months
where the close to close price has hit our
potential target within a month.
If we assume we split the target over
three months, we would have to see just
under minus 10% returns each month.
And again, if we look at the percentile
table, there's only about a 15 to 20%
chance of that happening on a given month.
And it would need to happen three times in
a row for us to kind of hit our target.
That's obviously not impossible, but it is
pretty difficult.
Looking over to the high to low range
distribution, there's a 10% price change
or more between,
the high and the low on around 90% of
months, which sounds like it's a little
bit more promising, but that does include
up months as well as down months.
And so you can kind of see here how short
ideas become quite difficult to figure out
suitable stops and targets for.
But you do have to remember when you're
going through this sort of analysis that
you have to have shorts in the portfolio
for balance and in order to make your
portfolio suitable for all market
conditions.
So again, as I said previously, what this
is going to come down to is starting with
some hard numbers and just trying to play
around with figures to see what can work
in terms of a three to one reward to risk
ratio,
whilst also obtaining a plausible target
and not having a stop that's going to be
triggered too easily.
So for this example, something more like
the 70th or 75th percentage rank might
work.
That means a stop somewhere between 8.4
and 10%.
So with that being said, let's enter some
data into the orange cells here and get
some price outputs for a stop and a target
for this stock.
And we're going to assume a 9% stop here
that gives us a 27% target and the current
price is 645 spot 89.
And so when those figures are entered, you
can see we get a stock value of 587 spot
76 and a target of 820 spot 28.
Now there is something else that we need
to consider when setting stops and targets
for individual stocks.
And that is that during strong bull
markets, for example, all of your shorts
can get stopped out purely because of
market conditions.
And in fact, this can of course happen in
the reverse as well.
And the thing to consider here is that
just because the market might move
significantly,
we don't want to very quickly find
ourselves in a situation where one side of
our portfolio has been wiped out since
that's going to result in a huge increase
in portfolio risk.
We need to maintain some balance in the
portfolio based on our fundamental
outlook.
And this is where some of the limits that
I'm going to mention later come into play.
So in those circumstances, we have a few
choices.
Either we abandon or change our stops.
We trade out and replace the ideas, or we
use different stop measures to help
navigate through the period.
Now, abandoning stops entirely is
obviously a bad idea since it allows human
biases to run riot and changing them is
viable, but only with plenty of market
experience.
Trading out and replacing the ideas is or
can work well, but unless you have a lot
of ideas ready in volatile conditions, it
may not be possible to do that.
And lastly, using different measures can
be a little bit complex.
But that being said, let me explore that
last option with you quickly.
One of the ways to deal with the issue of
market triggered stops for individual
positions is to combine ideas into long
short pairs or spreads and create stops
and targets around the pair of trades
rather than the individual trades.
That mitigates the market risk effect on
stops somewhat since market moves that
affect one position in the pair should
have the opposite effect in the opposing
position in terms of profit and loss.
Now, Anton briefly mentioned a way you can
do this by looking at spreads and went
through a simple example that works when
you assume an equal number of shares on
each side of the spread.
What I want to do here is build on that
slightly with a more robust template for
calculating stops and targets for spreads
where you can choose the exposure that
you're taking to each side of the spread
and work out reasonable stops and targets
from there.
Now, when I go through this stuff,
something to bear in mind is that spread
stops and targets are not a direct
substitute for individual trade stops and
targets.
They should be used in combination because
they can help in certain circumstances, as
I mentioned previously.
So here is the spread template that you
can use to conduct this analysis.
Now, as you can see, there are a few
structural differences with this sheet
compared to the single asset distribution
of returns template.
Firstly, we need two sets of prices for
both the long and short side of the trade.
And you can see here I've got Zinger
adjusted closed prices in column B, which
is where the prices of the long side of
the trade should go.
And I've got the align prices in or align
technology prices in column C, where the
short side of the trade goes.
From those two columns of price data,
returns are calculated for each stock in
columns D and E.
And then a weighted return is calculated
for this mini portfolio of two stocks in
column A.
Now, you'll notice that I don't have any
open high or low price data columns for
this template because it's unnecessary
since we cannot calculate high to low
price changes for spread data.
So we have to use close to close data
only.
Now, in column P, there are a few orange
cells that require our user input.
Firstly, in cells P2 and P3, you need to
fill in the gross exposures for the long
and short position respectively.
In this example, I've set the exposure to
$10,000 on each side.
And from those figures, the percentage
weighting is worked out in the cells
below.
Those values are then used to generate
constantly weighted portfolio returns or
spread returns in column F.
And those returns are then the returns
used in our distribution analysis.
And that in turn helps us find mental
stops and targets for the spread position
in dollar terms.
Now, one thing to consider here with this
template is that when you come to pasting
adjusted close prices for your long and
short positions in columns B and C
respectively,
you need to make sure that obviously the
dates align.
So that means the dates are correct in
column A for both sets of prices.
And you also need to make sure that the
length of the data set is the same for
both stocks,
which basically means you can only use a
historical period that is common to both
stocks, both positions.
And that's going to result in basically
using the dates from whichever stock has
the shorter data set.
So let's have a look at this data now and
figure out what might be a reasonable
mental stop and target for this pairs
trade.
If we look at the histogram data and the
summary statistics that we have,
the first thing that jumps out is that
this trade as a pair is much less volatile
than the two component parts,
which makes sense because we're removing
lots of market volatility by having a long
and a short position.
How do we know it's less volatile?
Well, we can see pretty clearly from the
histogram that it's very, very rare for
this spread to return anything outside of
plus or minus 15%.
And we can also see that the standard
deviation is less than half of that which
we had for the other stocks.
So let's have a look at our results now
and see in terms of creating stops and
targets.
If we were to use a stop that was
historically triggered 30% of the time,
the value would be 4.3%, 4.36% to be
precise.
If we were to use a stop that was
historically triggered 15% of the time,
the value would be 7.39%.
So that is the kind of range that we're
working within.
And let's say that for now we settle on a
6% stop.
That means our target should be three
times that.
So that's 18%.
And let's have a think about how that adds
up.
Well, we can see that this spread has
never actually achieved that within a
monthly period.
So that's not a great start.
But we also need to be aware of the fact
that historically this trade has performed
very poorly.
But that doesn't mean that it's going to
going forward.
Again, this comes back to the future
percentages hopefully shifting in a
beneficial way to you as a trader,
because you've done good fundamental work.
The other thing to consider here is that
just because the target has never been
attained in a month,
doesn't mean that it won't be over three
months.
If we say that we need to obtain about a
5% to 6% return a month,
then each month based on historical close
to close data, there's about a 15% chance
of that happening.
Now, obviously, that isn't great
statistically.
But you've also got to remember that we
can't generate high to low ranges here.
And so the actual volatility range covered
might be quite a bit higher.
And we just can't see that.
As I've said a few times already, this
does come back to a discretionary decision
that's based upon probabilistic raw data.
Only you can really decide what might
work.
What we're trying to do here is give you
the numerical tools to help you make that
decision.
So let's just say for this example, we're
going to stick with a 6% stop and an 18%
target,
because over the next three months, we
think that there's going to be enough
volatility for that target to be attained.
And we don't want to move the stop any
lower because we want to give the pair
room to move.
If we enter those values in salespeople
respectively, then we can see a dollar
stop loss of $1,200 and a dollar target of
$3,600.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that the mental stop loss
you've chosen equates to a loss of $1,200
over the two positions.
And at that point, you should be cutting
both positions.
And this might happen when one position
makes $500 and one loses $1,700 for
example.
It might happen when both lose $600.
It doesn't really matter.
The point is that the dollar stop loss is
a cumulative stop over the two positions.
The same is true for the target and the
positions can be scaled into when the soft
target is reached and the stop is then
shifted upwards.
So let's think about an example of that.
We reach our target here if the cumulative
P&L over the two trades gets to plus
$3,600.
Let's say that happens during a strong
bull market run and that figure is reached
through a $2 loss and a $3,800 win from
the long.
If that's the case, and I'm ignoring any
deposits or withdrawals here, then our
short exposure will be $10,200 after a
$200 loss.
Because remember, the short has to
increase in price and therefore exposure
in order to generate a loss.
And our long exposure will be $13,800
since a $3,800 profit on the long side
increases exposure by $3,800.
So the target has been hit.
What happens next?
Well, there are basically two decisions to
make here.
Firstly, do you want to add to the
position?
And by position here, I mean the entire
long short pair.
Generally, you want to add to your
winners, of course, subject to position,
size and constraints.
And so that leads us to the second
decision, which is if you are going to add
to the position, in what proportion do you
want to do it?
If we update the gross exposure sales for
the long and short side to $13,800 and
$10,200 respectively, then you can see the
weighting of the significantly.
There's now a 57.5% weighting on the long
side and a 42.5% weighting on the short
side.
Now, let's say, for example, that we want
to increase the overall position sizes
because the trade is working.
And we're looking to add another $10,000
gross exposure across the two trades.
You might want to realign the weightings
to 50% each in that case, or you might
want to overweight one side of the trade.
There are lots of reasons why you might
want to do either of those.
And those decisions are going to be kind
of up to you and the sort of portfolio
that you're running and the balance that
you want in your portfolio.
As an example, though, I'm going to assume
here that we think the long side of the
trade is doing well.
And also the short side isn't doing too
badly, considering such a strong bull
market backdrop.
Also, let's assume that if these positions
aren't reasonably balanced in terms of
dollar exposure terms, then it's
detrimental to our portfolio construction
and potentially exceeds preventative risk
limits for beta and net exposure.
So, for those reasons, in this example,
we're going to rebalance this pair to be
equally weighted.
Now, at the moment, given the long side
has increased in exposure to $13,800 and
the short side has increased to an
exposure of $10,200, we have a current
gross exposure of $24,000 over the pair.
If we add $10,000, then we should have
$34,000 over the pair.
And if it's equally weighted in cash
terms, then both Align Technologies and
Zinger should have a $17,000 exposure
each.
So if we enter those values into cells P2
and P3 and we decide to keep the stock
percent the same at this point, then our
stock from this point is minus $2,040.
But you need to remember that this value
is applied on top of the previous P&L we
had, which was plus $3,600.
So that means that the actual running stop
for this pairs trade would be plus $1,560.
Now, hopefully that makes sense to you
guys.
And by the way, if you did decide to
change the weightings when you added
exposure to the trades, then that would
also change the historical spread returns.
And you'd need to reassess to see if the
same stock and target percentages were
suitable.
They would then be applied on top of the
prior profit.
So for example, if to some reason your new
stock became 10%, which would be a $3,400
loss on a $34,000 exposure pair.
Then your mental stock loss would actually
be $200 in P&L, which is equal to the
$3,600 original profit from reaching our
first soft target minus $3,400, which is
the new stock.
Again, I hope that makes sense to you
guys.
I just want to give you all the sort of
options and various ways to handle these
scenarios and you guys can kind of decide
what works for you.
Now, there are a couple of things to
consider here before I'm going to move on
to looking at the average true range
percentage analysis, which is firstly,
when you work out stops and targets for
spreads,
they have to just be mental notes because
you can't program them into your brokerage
platform.
And secondly, the spread calculations
should be looked at in combination with
the individual stops and targets that you
have for positions.
You want to be using the information in a
combination in order to make well-informed
decision individual position stops and
targets.
It's sometimes better also to keep those
as mental or manual stops rather than
automated ones through your brokerage
platform,
because it will then allow you to be
flexible in scenarios like I've just
described.
Now, whether you run manual or automated
stops on individual positions or a
mixture, it's up to you.
I'm just pointing out some considerations
at this point.
Okay, guys, let's move on to briefly
talking through an average true range
percentage or ATRP for short volatility
analysis,
which is another way you guys can generate
stops and targets for individual stocks.
This method is going to be quite a bit
quicker than doing a distribution of
returns analysis.
But equally, it doesn't really provide as
much detail either.
Now, in this section, I'm not going to
actually show you how to build an ATRP
sheet from scratch.
And instead, I'm just going to jump
straight into these template sheets here
and talk you through how you can use them.
If you are interested in generating an
ATRP from scratch, then you'll be able to
see that in the IPLT course.
And you can, of course, have a look at how
I've built these templates and backward
engineer them if you want to do so.
And it really isn't that difficult to do
that.
And it will probably only take you about
30 minutes to figure it all out.
So as you can see in the spreadsheet here,
I've got two sheets that calculate ATRP
values using weekly and quarterly data
respectively.
As Anton said in the previous video,
weekly ATRP values provide a good guide
for stock losses and quarterly ATRP values
provide good estimates for targets.
And this is just something really that
when you've been trading for a long time,
you just come to understand through
practice rather than something that can be
proven mathematically or anything like
that.
Now, before we look at these sheets in any
detail, let me briefly describe what the
average true range percentage calculation
is trying to capture.
Now, I think it will be fairly clear to
you guys that having an understanding of
the high to low range for an asset can be
a useful metric for understanding
volatility because it tries to capture the
maximum price movement over a certain
length of period.
Now, I say it tries to measure the maximum
price movement because it doesn't always
succeed.
There are times when stocks can move
significantly in the pre or post market
and these price movements are ignored by a
simple high to low range.
So all that the true range percentage
calculation does is adjust for that.
So it finds the actual maximum price
movement over a period, including any
moves that happen outside of market hours.
The average true range percentage is then
a simple average of those true range
percentages over X number of periods.
So let's look at the weekly ATRP template
sheet now to try and make that a little
bit clearer.
OK, so in the left hand columns, what I
have here is weekly price data for align
technologies going back to or from, I
should say, December the 20th, 2021.
And as we had in the distribution of
returns template, you can see the open
high close prices in columns B to F.
In column G, we have a calculation column,
which simply the high to low range for
each period.
So each week in this case.
And in column H, we have the true range
percentage calculation for each week.
And if we take a look at the formula in
cell H2 to see what it looks like, then
you get this.
Now, this formula might look complicated,
but it's really not.
Remember, the goal of the true range is to
find the maximum range over a period
inclusive of any out of hours market
moves.
So you can see that the first part of the
formula here is trying to find the maximum
between three values.
The first value is whatever value we see
in the adjacent cell in column G.
So that's just our intra period high to
low range.
The second value is the high of the
current period minus the close of the
previous period in its absolute format.
Using the close of the previous periods
makes sure that any out of hours moves are
accounted for within the calculation.
And then this formula is basically just
taking the maximum range from the intra
period high to low, the previous close to
the low and the previous close to the
high.
That yields a maximum true range and then
to express that as a percentage, we just
divide it by the current periods open,
which is what the last part of the formula
does.
Now, hopefully that makes sense to you
guys.
But if not, just take some time to look at
it again when you download this file.
So after we've generated a time series of
true range percentage values in column H,
we can then take averages over various
periods of time, which I've done over here
in this box to the right hand side.
The reason why we take averages is so that
we don't rely on a single data point to
come up with an analytical conclusion,
like a stop or target.
And I've chosen to take averages over
various periods here so that it gives us
an insight into how the average data
points are.
And that's the reason why we use an ATRP
for this stock as information for us to
use in terms of picking an appropriate
bucket.
So what this data here is saying is that
Align Technologies has an ATRP value of 9%
over the last month, which is four weeks
of data.
It has an ATRP of 8.42% over the last
quarter, which is the last 13 weeks of
data and so on.
As I've mentioned before, when we look at
data like this, it's all about finding a
balance between using more recent data and
enough data that the conclusions are
statistically significant.
The balance is obviously up to you, but
what I would say is that for this stock,
it looks like the weekly ATRP has been
about 8% to 10% through almost its entire
trading history.
And so picking a stock value in that range
is probably pretty sensible.
Now, what you guys might remember is that
when we looked at this same stock using
the DOR analysis, we actually got to
exactly the same conclusion of about an 8%
to 10% stop being reasonable for this
stock.
So we know we're on the right track here.
And like I said, we know this works from
experience.
But if in doubt, you can, of course,
always double check the numbers against
each other using both the DOR and ATRP
analysis.
Let's have a quick look at the quarterly
ATRP values now for aligned technologies.
All the analysis is the same here, but I
just want to talk through the ATRP values
that we're seeing quickly.
So firstly, with quarterly data, we
clearly have much higher ATRP numbers.
That should be obvious since the
volatility is bound to be larger over
longer periods of time.
We also have quite a bit more variation in
the results over different timeframes.
But that's actually largely due to mostly
the one year quarterly ATRP value, which
only uses four data points.
And so we can sort of disregard that as
fairly unreliable since there are only
four periods in the calculation.
That being said, some of these other
values are being skewed a bit by including
periods of exceptional market volatility,
such as in the 2020.
And if we think about what our stop range
was based on the weekly ATRP values that
we had in the previous sheet,
then we're looking in the range of eight
to 10%.
So given that we want a target that is
around three, three times that figure.
So about 24% to 30%.
And what we can ask ourselves is, does
that add up with what we're seeing here in
the quarterly ATRPs?
And I would say in this case, sort of.
If you were to calculate ATRPs on a
quarterly basis without including
historical market crashes, then it
certainly would.
But we don't want to do that because it
biases the data.
So what we have then is a weekly ATRP
suggesting a stop somewhere in the range
of eight to 10%.
And a quarterly ATRP suggesting a target
of somewhere in the range of 35 to 40%.
Now there are many ways you could approach
this situation using the data available to
come up with an answer.
And my general advice here is that as long
as you're using common sense and logic,
the answer you come up with will be valid.
One way you could look at this data is to
simply take some kind of middle ground.
So what if we were to take the top end of
the stop and the bottom end of the target?
That would mean a stop of 10% and a target
of 35%.
Does that still provide at least a three
times ratio?
Yes.
So maybe that's a reasonable solution to
consider.
Another way you could look at this is that
you might say the current market
environment isn't applicable to historic
periods of huge volatility.
And therefore you don't think the target
generated by the quarterly ATRP should be
skewed as high as it is.
One way to tackle that is simply by using
a three times stop value that you're happy
with and ignoring the quarterly data.
And another is calculating what a
quarterly value might look like when you
don't include those historic market
crashes.
You've got to be quite careful if you do
that.
Typically I advise using as much data as
possible, like I said, for statistical
significance.
But what I'm trying to get across to you
guys is that there are a number of ways to
approach this problem.
Don't get too bogged down in the details.
Just make sure that you choose something
sensible and that it's based on the
volatility of the stock and then you stick
to it.
So now let's discuss how you can actually
use these ATRP templates in practice,
meaning how can you actually import new or
different stock data into them and then go
through an analysis.
So I'm going to start with the weekly
template first, and this one's really
simple.
All you need to do here to update the data
is remove all the current data you see in
columns A to F by selecting it and
pressing delete on the keyboard and then
replacing that data with new price data
downloaded from Yahoo Finance or another
appropriate source.
So let's do that now for our long Zinger
position.
As before, to obtain Zinger price data,
I'm just going to head over to Yahoo
Finance and then use the search bar at the
top to navigate to the Zinger stock page.
From there, within the historical data
tab, we want weekly prices this time and
again, the entire price history available.
After that, you can just click apply and
download and then use the downloaded file
in Excel.
And at this point, before importing the
data into our template, there's a couple
of adjustments that we need to make.
Firstly, I'm going to make the date column
slightly wider by clicking and dragging
the intersection of column A and B to the
right slightly.
Then we need to arrange this data in
descending order, meaning the latest
weekly data is displayed at the top of the
sheet.
And as we've done before to do that, you
just select any one of the column titles
and then go to data on the ribbon followed
by filter.
And then using the filter option in column
A, the date column, you just choose to
sort the data from newest to oldest.
Now, at this point, you might see an
incomplete period of data at the top of
the sheet.
And to deal with that, you can just delete
it.
Fortunately, here, I don't have to deal
with that.
And so now the data is ready to copy
across to our template.
But remember, we don't need the volume
column.
So we're only going to copy across columns
A to F.
To do that, I'm just selecting those
columns and pressing control C on the
keyboard to copy the data.
And then I'm going to open the weekly ATRP
template and paste this data into the
sheet.
Now, we need to make sure that this data
is pasted as values in order to keep all
the original formatting the same.
So here I'm going to right click column A
and choose to paste as values using the
one, two, three clipboard option.
So with our Zinger data in the file, we
just need to double check the calculation
columns and make sure the series of
formulas that we see in columns G and H
are the correct length for our new price
set price data set.
Column G needs to be the same length as
the price data.
And so in this case, we want to delete
these redundant formulas from rows 526
down.
The reason why these formulas are there,
remember, is just because the previous
stock in the template, which was the line
technologies, had a much longer data set.
In column H, we do almost exactly the same
thing.
But this time we need to remove the
contents of the cells from row 525 down
instead of 526.
The reason being that the true range
percentage formulas in column H require
price data from the previous period.
And so the time series has to be one
period shorter.
If we take a look at the ATRP values in
our summary box on the right hand side for
this stock,
we can see again that we get to a fairly
similar conclusion to that which we got
with the DOR analysis for this stock.
So the range we're looking at here is
somewhere between 7% and 9%.
And previously with the DOR analysis, we
assumed a stock of 8% was reasonable.
And that fits in perfectly again with our
kind of range here.
However, we do get an interesting bit of
extra detail here that we kind of didn't
see in the DOR analysis.
And that is that within the last quarter
or so, the volatility in this stock has
been going quite a bit higher based on
ATRP values.
Now, a quarter of data isn't really enough
to make us shift our analysis for what
value of stock we use.
But what it does provide is a little more
confidence that we might be getting into
this stock at the right time since
volatility is trending up.
Okay, so let's go over to the quarterly
template now.
And this one does take just a little bit
more work in order to import prices
correctly.
So to begin with, just as with the weekly
ATRP template, when you're looking to
analyze updated or different stock data
entirely,
the first thing to do with this is delete
the data already in the template sheet.
Again, that means selecting columns A to F
and pressing delete on the keyboard to
delete the contents of those cells.
Now, in order to import quarterly price
data, we're actually going to have to
download monthly price data
and perform a number of manipulations in
order to get it ready to use.
So I'm going to go through our long Zinger
example here to show you how to do this.
Firstly, we need to head back to Yahoo
Finance and this time, instead of
downloading weekly price data for the
stock we want,
we're going to download monthly prices.
So here, all I'm doing is from the same
page we were on before, just changing the
frequency to monthly from weekly
and then making sure we're still looking
at the maximum time period available and
then clicking apply and downloading the
data.
After that, I'm just going to open the
file again.
And to begin with, I'm just going to do
exactly the same as we did with our weekly
data,
which was firstly to expand the date
column width.
And secondly, to add a filter so that we
can sort the dates from the newest to
oldest, meaning in descending order.
With that done, we again want to make sure
that any incomplete periods are removed.
But here again, we don't have an issue
with that.
So at this stage, what we actually need to
do is perform a manipulation on our open,
high and low columns of data,
which is going to help us transform the
data from monthly to quarterly values.
So in columns H, I and J, I'm just going
to head the columns open, high and low
respectively.
The open is going to be recalculated for
each month as the open from two months
before.
So in cell H2, the formula will just be
equals B4.
The high is going to be recalculated for
the latest three months of data.
So the formula in cell I2 will be equals
max open brackets C2 to C4.
And finally, the new low is going to be
the minimum of the latest three months of
data.
And so the formula in cell J2 will be
equals min open brackets D2 to D4.
Now from there, all of these formulas can
just be copied down to the end of the
price series.
And then all you need to do is just double
check at the bottom of these series that
the formulas are working correctly
and that we don't have any errors or weird
values.
Now you can see here that the final two
open prices are displaying zero values.
And that's because the formulas that we're
using in those cells are trying to
reference prices that don't exist.
And so those two values can just be
deleted.
Okay, so the formulas all look good now.
And so we're ready to update the open high
and low values we see in columns B2D with
these new numbers.
To do that, I'm just going to copy columns
H2J and paste them as values into columns
B2D.
And then having done that, we can actually
delete columns H2J entirely.
All right, so we're almost there now.
There's just one more manipulation to make
before we copy this data into our
quarterly template.
And that is that we need to remove some of
this monthly data so that we're only left
with quarterly data points.
Now, I think the easiest way to do that is
to filter out unwanted months of the year.
So basically, we're only left with four
quarters in each annual period.
Now, to do that, I'm going to use a
formula in column H, which just returns a
number value for each month corresponding
to the date seen in column A.
And the formula we can use for that, which
I'm going to type here into cell H2, is
equals month, open brackets, then a cell
reference, the cell reference for this one
is going to be A2.
Now, as you can see, when that formula is
entered, it returns a value of 12, the
12th month in the year, which is December.
And that is because that's the month
that's defined in the corresponding date
cell, so cell A2.
So with that formula entered, we can copy
it down.
And now, since we have all of the month
values defined in a new column, what we
can do is filter that column for the
months of the year that we want to remove.
So that we're only left with quarterly
data points.
Now, to do that, we need to reapply a
filter to the headings in this table and
then select the filter in our new column,
column H.
And from there, what we can do is uncheck
all of the months and then recheck just
the months that we want to remove.
So, for example, if I were to check the
value of one here and press OK, the data
table would only show price data from
January in each year, and then I could
choose to delete that data.
So in this case, what we want to do is
make sure we keep the latest data
available, which is in December.
So what I'm going to do here is check all
of the data for the months of November and
October, and then leave September since
September is one quarter behind December.
Then I'm going to check the months August
and July and leave June and then check May
and April and leave March and then finally
check February and January.
So basically, you can see here that what
I'm doing is selecting all the months of
the year that I want to remove so that
we're only left with quarterly data based
on the fact that we want to keep December
data because that's our latest month of
data.
If I press OK now, you can see that all
the data I deselected, which is the months
of December, September, June and March no
longer appear in the table.
So all I'm going to do at this point is
delete all of this data by selecting row
to pressing control shift and down on the
keyboard and then right clicking within
that data and selecting delete row.
So after that, all that's needed is to
remove the filter and you'll see that
we're just left with quarterly data, which
is now ready to copy across to our
quarterly ATRP template.
So to copy that data across, it's the same
data, just use control C to copy the
columns A to F and once they're selected
and then paste them as values into column
A of the template sheet.
So similarly to weekly data, we need to
check our calculation columns in G and H
again now in the template and just make
sure that they're the correct length to
match our price data.
Now, in this case, we need to delete some
formulas again.
So row 42 down for column G, our high to
low range and from 41 down for our true
range column, column H.
So with all of that done, we can finally
check the quarterly ATRP values we have
for this stock, which looks like a range
from about 27 to 31%, which is quite a
tight range.
And if we think about the stock value
obtained from our weekly ATRP, it was
anywhere in the range of seven to 9%.
And so just by multiplying that range by
three, we do actually get pretty close to
the suggested target using quarterly ATRP
values.
And you can approach these figures in
exactly the same way as I talked about to
the previous stock, Align Technologies.
It really just boils down to a
discretionary decision that should be
guided by the volatility seen in weekly
and quarterly ATRP values.
And as long as you're using common sense
and logic to get to your answer, you're
going to be fine.
What I would say, though, about the
quarterly Zinger data that we have here is
that it is a very short time series, which
doesn't really inspire confidence in terms
of generating statistical significant or
statistically significant analytical
outcomes, I should say.
So that is something to bear in mind. And
one thing I would suggest if you're
dealing with particularly short time
series of data like this is that you
probably want to wait the weekly ATRP
values a bit more than what you're seeing
in the quarterly sheet.
What I mean by that is once you've come up
with a stop value using the weekly ATRP,
it might be a better idea just to make
your target equal to three times your stop
rather than worrying too much about the
quarterly data.
And you might now be asking what
constitutes a short time series.
I can't tell you that exactly. But for me,
I do like to see generally in any data
that I use at least 75 to 100 data points
in order to try and get some statistical
significance out of the data that I'm
using.
But like I said, everyone is different.
Now, guys, I mentioned at the beginning of
the video that I'm also going to talk
about some other preventative risk
management metrics besides just stops and
targets.
So let's do that now. I'm going to bring
up another spreadsheet here, which
hopefully you guys remember from video 20,
our beta calculation lesson.
As a reminder, what we're looking at here
really is a portfolio risk monitor in the
orange cells.
We enter our portfolio positions with
longs in the top section and shorts in the
bottom.
And the details included here are the
company name and ticker, the stock beta
value, the current price and the number of
shares held in a stock.
As a quick reminder, the stock beta value
is a measure of sensitivity of a stock to
the market.
So a value of one would suggest that for a
1% move in the market, the stock also
moves 1% in the same direction on average.
I explained things in a lot more detail in
video 20 regarding beta and its uses, its
drawbacks and how you can calculate it.
So if you can't remember, just head back
to that video and give it another look.
So from those details in the orange cells,
various calculations are made in the
adjacent white cells, including gross
exposure, net dollar exposure, net dollar
weighting and weighted beta calculations.
Again, just as a reminder at this point,
the gross exposure of a position is the
current price multiplied by the number of
shares.
The net exposure of a position is the
gross exposure multiplied by one for a
long or minus one for a short.
So basically short positions end up having
negative net exposures.
The net dollar weighting is the net
exposure divided by the gross exposure in
the portfolio.
And the weighted beta is the beta of the
stock multiplied by the net weight.
And this is effectively kind of a
volatility weighted net weight value, if
you like.
At the portfolio level, the sum of all of
the individual position gross exposures
equates to the portfolio gross exposure.
And equally, the sum of all the individual
position net exposures equates to the
portfolio net exposure.
Likewise, the sum of all the individual
net dollar weights equates to the
portfolio net dollar weight.
And also the sum of all of the individual
net weighted beta values equates to the
portfolio beta.
So let's have a look at these metrics for
this portfolio in turn.
Firstly, we can see the gross dollar
exposure in cell G33 is equal to $99,810.
So basically, this trader is running about
$100,000 of risk.
Now, we don't know what the situation is
behind the scenes for this trader.
And what I mean by that is we don't
actually know what amount of margin is
deposited in the account in order to
achieve that $100,000 gross exposure.
But if he or she is based in the US, then
their gross exposure will be capped at two
times their margin.
So at a minimum, that would mean that the
account has $50,000 of margin.
If, however, this trader is based in a
country that allows CFDs, and these are
indeed CFD positions in the portfolio,
then the leverage limit is actually likely
to be much higher, perhaps up to 10 times.
However, does that mean that it's sensible
to use that leverage?
Most definitely not.
If this trader was using 10 times
leverage, then the deposited margin only
needs to be $10,000 to put on this
$100,000 of risk.
And that might sound good, but it also
means that the portfolio would only need
to drop in value by 10% for the entire
margin to be wiped out.
So that's why portfolio gross exposure
limits are essential.
Using some leverage can be useful in order
to increase the risk and opportunity of
your portfolio, especially when we're
running a long, short book.
But it does need to be monitored and
limited to prevent sort of catastrophic
loss.
For a well run long short portfolio, about
two to four times leverage for stocks is
okay.
Going much higher than that becomes pretty
dangerous.
And when you're starting out as new
traders, you want to keep the leverage on
the lower end of that range.
And then you can build into it over time,
subject to your sort of own success.
So let's say, for example, this trader
here is starting out and he's deposited
$50,000 on margin.
Having a portfolio gross exposure of
$99,000 in leverage factor of almost two,
that's well within an appropriate gross
exposure or leverage limit.
However, if he's only deposited $20,000,
then his gross exposure is almost five
times his margin deposit.
And he's almost definitely running too
much risk.
If the portfolio value dropped by 10%, in
that example, his margin would half.
Obviously, when you guys are thinking
about gross exposure and leverage limits
for your own portfolios, they're going to
be completely up to you.
But as I said, as a guide, exceeding four
times leverage, even as an accomplished
retail trader, is probably unwise.
Let's think about net dollar or net cash
exposure now.
And this metric clearly gives us an
insight into how long or short we are on a
net basis across the portfolio.
And the general principle here is that as
long short traders and portfolio managers,
we want to always have some balance across
the portfolio,
which is part of what makes the strategy
so good because it can be traded
successfully through all market
conditions.
So here, the dollar net exposure is $114,
which in net weight terms is only 0.11%.
And based on that, this portfolio is
basically market neutral in its current
state.
Although, as I said in the beta video,
this is by no means a full story because
it doesn't actually account for the
individual asset betas and, of course, the
portfolio beta.
In practice, you can have portfolios that
are roughly cash neutral like this one,
but yet on a beta adjusted basis, they're
significantly net short or significantly
net long.
Now, as it happens in this example, the
portfolio beta is almost zero as well.
So in its current setup, we would expect
this portfolio to be very market neutral,
meaning that its value should move pretty
much independently to the stock market.
We can only assume then that in this case,
the manager of this portfolio doesn't
really have a fundamental bias or thesis
about the market direction going forward,
whether that's long or short.
You guys know by now that generally you
should have at least some bias in terms of
market direction, because if you don't, it
probably means that you just haven't done
your macro fundamental work properly.
But that being said, there are, of course,
circumstances whereby you might want to be
very neutral, like in this portfolio.
Now, in terms of portfolio beta, for the
most part, a sensible range to operate in
is plus 30% to minus 30%, or in decimal
format, plus 0.3 to minus 0.3.
So a beta value in the range of, let's
say, plus to minus 5%, like this
portfolio, we would say is very market
neutral.
A 10% tilt in either direction represents
a fairly weak bias, whether it's long or
short, and anything above 20% is quite a
strong bias.
And then outside the limits of plus or
minus 30% starts to represent such a
strong bias on market direction that the
benefits of long short portfolio
management start to deteriorate.
And so I would say that that range should
only be exceeded in exceptional
circumstances or with incredible eviction.
It can be applied to the dollar or cash
net weight in this portfolio, which in
this example is 0.11%.
As I said before, however, as I said in
video 20, net cash weight is just kind of
a crude measure of portfolio bias, since
it doesn't really account for the basis of
individual stocks.
And for that reason, we can actually
extend the acceptable range of net cash
weight to something more like 50%, so plus
50% to minus 50%, simply because it just
isn't as effective as a measure to capture
market risk or bias in the portfolio.
So, beta is the value that you should be
paying more attention to, but you must
also remember that beta isn't infallible
and there are some drawbacks of using
beta.
And if you want to find out more about
that, then you need to go back to video
20.
So, let's think about a scenario here in
this portfolio where these limits might be
broken and what we can do about it.
So, let's say that the market rallies
strongly by 10% over a couple of months
and as a result, increase in value.
Now, at this point, I'm just going to
arbitrarily increase the prices of these
long stocks in turn to reflect that
scenario now.
So, let's put the prices at 15, 98, 36,
22, 115 and 240.
Now, we're also going to assume here that
a couple of this trader's short positions
have done quite well over the period and
stayed flat.
But Lenar Corporation and Best Buy have
gone up in price by 10% with the market
and they've ended up both being stopped
out.
If I delete those two stocks from the
portfolio now, look what happens to the
portfolio beta.
It's gone from a value of minus 5% to a
value of 48%.
If our beta values then are perfectly
accurate and the market then corrects back
to where it was dropping around 10%,
then in theory, if we do nothing to change
the structure of this portfolio,
it should decrease in value by 5% given
that our new beta value is close to 0.5.
Now, that might not sound like much, but
it doesn't account for leverage.
If you're 4 times levered, then that's
going to mean your margin decreases by
20%,
which then seems a lot more significant
when you think about how easily avoidable
this scenario was.
All that would have had to happen was to
rebalance some of the position weightings
or reinstate a couple of new shorts in the
portfolio and then beta would have been
balanced.
Now, there are obviously an infinite
number of scenarios that could happen in
the real world that would represent a
similar thing.
But the point here is really that it's
very important to pay attention to your
risk limits.
They're called preventative risk limits
for a reason because they are a proactive
rather than reactive approach to making
sure losses are limited.
Gross exposure and leverage limits prevent
excess losses because they control the
amplification effects of leverage on
downturns in portfolio value.
Net exposure and beta limits prevent
excess losses because they limit how
exposed our portfolios are to market moves
that we may or may not get right.
And even if we do, as we saw in the
previous example, we can then actually get
whipsawed with our stops quite quickly and
lose much more than we should.
Preventative risk management metrics like
these and stops and targets are all there
to help improve our trading performance.
And that will then be reflected in
performance metrics like our R scores and
our percent winning trades and many
others.
I'm going to go into in a bit more detail
in a couple of videos time.
So that's all I really wanted to cover in
this video.
Hopefully that all makes sense and you
guys can see the importance of PRM
measures.
The key points to take away from this
video are really firstly that you need to
make sure you generate sensible stops and
targets based on the volatility of assets
that you're trading.
You want to set hard stops and soft
targets to try and help remove the human
biases that we tend to have.
However, we can't just pick a level of the
stop and target and hope that it works.
And neither can we pick a one size fits
all that we can use across all trades in
all conditions.
You need to choose stops and targets based
on the volatility of the underlying
assets.
And all assets have different volatilities
and those volatilities change with time as
well.
And that's why you need to do volatility
analyses like distribution of returns
analysis and average true range percentage
analysis so that you can figure out what
numbers might work for different stocks at
different times.
And remember guys, the stops and targets
you choose for each position should find a
balance that means that the stops aren't
triggered too easily, but the targets are
still attainable.
Now, despite these values being driven by
hard data as you will have gathered from
this video and Anton's presentation
previously, there is definitely a
discretionary component that you'll need
to use in combination with that hard data.
The data itself doesn't provide clear cut
answers.
You need to be able to think about what
the data means and fine tune the outcomes
on a discretionary basis if you think it's
appropriate.
Now, on that note, whilst we're aiming for
hard stops and soft targets in our
individual positions, we also have to
understand that market dynamics might
dictate that adjustments need to be made
to stop us being stopped out on multiple
longs or shorts at the same time.
Again, the decision you make on how to
handle that is discretionary, but one
method that we looked at in this video is
to split trades into long short pairs and
monitor stops and targets on paired
positions that are relatively market
neutral.
To do that, you'll need to move to a more
mental stop approach rather than
programming them into your brokerage
platform.
Because firstly, brokers don't support
stops on spread positions, but secondly,
when using individual and spread stops and
targets in combination, there is no choice
really, but to add in a discretionary
component in the decision making process.
Now, I'm not trying to say here that all
of this work just leads to discretionary
choices that don't matter and don't help
us with human biases. Far from it, in
fact.
What I am trying to say is that we should
be using volatility to remove human
errors.
But equally, we have to be realistic that
there will be one has to be used.
Otherwise, we might actually end up making
huge mistakes and doing things like
letting all of our shorts or some of our
shorts and longs get stopped out all at
once,
which then subsequently puts portfolio
risk through the roof.
That was the scenario we played out
towards the end of the video within the
context of looking at other PRM risk
metrics as well,
namely gross exposure limits, net exposure
limits and portfolio beta limits.
Now, remember, guys, that these limits are
there to help guide us and prevent
thoughtless mistakes.
And the limits that you set for these
metrics are, again, discretionary and
should be based on your own trading and
risk profile.
But hopefully, that being said, the ranges
that I talked about in the scenario we
discussed at the end there will give you a
good idea of what some sensible numbers
might be.
Anyway, guys, that's all I wanted to say
on all of this stuff today.
I hope you guys enjoyed the video and I'll
see you later in the video series where
I'm going to talk about trading statistics
and performance measures.
OK, guys, so welcome back to the desk.
Let's have a quick recap there.
So what we looked at was trading
psychology and risk management,
preventative risk management measures.
So what do we look at first? We looked at
human psychology and the tendencies of
human psychology as they pertain to the
skill set of money management.
OK, so we looked at how this works in
practice with applying the distribution of
returns analysis,
the average true range percentage
calculations in setting sensible, hard
stop losses and targets for individual
stocks and also for spreads on stocks.
OK, so what we did, we discussed how to
treat stops and targets also as part of an
overall long short portfolio,
an overall long short stock portfolio. But
it is important to remember always because
we are long short portfolio managers and
traders that we don't just apply blanket
rule across the board.
We don't just apply all hard stops and
targets to all positions in a long short
portfolio all the time across the entire
portfolio,
because we will obviously have correlation
in the portfolio.
It is totally situational and there isn't
a rule book that you can just buy and just
put into place all of the rules that a
book tells you.
OK, so for example, you can't go into a
long short portfolio dynamic and say, for
example, five out of six, five or six
positions out of 10.
Have to all have hard stop losses and soft
targets on them. It just doesn't work like
that. OK, if you try to apply a rule book
here, guys, where the rule applies to all
stocks all the time in all situations,
you're just going to get whipsawed by the
market because you're running a long short
portfolio and the market's going to go up
and down and you can't have a situation
where you're just going to get stopped out
on all your shorts when the market goes
up.
And if the market reverses and goes down,
you just get stopped out on all your
longs.
So the best you can do here all the time
is just take a balanced, cautious and
realistic approach. OK, so Chris also in
this video showed you how to work out the
distribution of returns analysis and the
ATRP in terms of the numbers in a
spreadsheet.
So you can actually use this now as a
template going forward to calculate
sensible and well about taking a well
balanced approach, a cautious approach,
calculate sensible stock losses and
realistic targets.
So he did this both for single stocks and
also for spreads. So if you are going to
run long short stock portfolios or in the
rest of the world CFD positions, what's
going to happen going forward?
You're going to be using these templates
to make sure that you're calculating
volatility properly and calculating
sensible stop losses and realistic targets
over the 20 to 60 day time horizon.
Now, Chris also went through some other
metrics as well, preventative risk
management metrics and also some
performance metrics.
So Chris looked at targeting an R score of
a minimum of 1.5. OK, on a win loss ratio
over time, over many trades, a target of
60 percent win rate and 40 percent loss
rate.
Loss rate. These are achievable targets.
They are realistic and they are sensible
targets as parameters that you should be
aiming for over the long term.
And in terms of preventative risk
management, what is actually happening
here is if you're setting those targets,
you are preventing yourself from ending up
in a situation that over a long period of
time, over many trades,
many trades becomes untenable. OK, so an R
score minimum of 1.5 and a win loss rate
of 60 40.
Now, Chris also looked at gross exposure
limits. If you're in the United States,
your gross exposure limits on a long short
portfolio, a stock portfolio is going to
be two times whatever the number is you
have deposited in your account.
Two times that rate. OK, you don't have a
choice.
OK, you don't have a choice. That's the
limit that brokers set for you in the rest
of the world.
When the rest of the world retail traders
are trading CFDs, the exposure limit can
be higher.
It can be up to five times what you have
in your account. But we would say a
sensible approach initially is to only go
for a maximum of four times what you put
in your account.
OK, so set a gross exposure limit that's
sensible, please make sure you stick to
it.
Also, Chris looked at beta adjusted net
exposure limits and he mentioned that the
kind of maximum is plus or minus 30% beta
adjusted position exposure limit in your
portfolio, your net exposure limit.
So try to stay within that if you start to
see yourself getting close to 30% or above
30%, it means you're bringing a lot of
market bias into your portfolio and it
means that you're not really necessarily
getting the single stock bias, the
idiosyncratic bias in your portfolio.
And if you go too far either way, then it
essentially becomes a market bet.
You're not really using using the stocks
to get a stock return.
You're using the stocks to get a market
return.
OK, Chris also mentioned cash for cash net
exposure and looked at a kind of plus or
minus limit of maximum 50%.
You need to know where this is as well.
You can only really go up to that type of
number if you really know what your beta
adjusted net is.
So, for example, you can have a plus 45%
cash for cash net exposure.
But in the background, the actual beta
adjusted net exposure might, for example,
be only 15%.
That's OK.
You just have to make sure that you know
where both of them are and both of them
are under control.
OK, so we're going to move on now to the
next video.
And we're going to be exploring more
aspects of psychology in trading.
And specifically, what we're going to be
looking at is eliminating emotion and
staying objective.
So previously, we've mentioned a few times
about reactive risk management, RRM, and
how it's impossible to teach that in a
video series.
But what is possible with RRM is to give
you some sort of perspective on how you
should think about handling your positions
when things start to pan out through the
life of a trade.
So when a position becomes a winner, loser
or a nothing position.
And what we call this is staying in
motion.
So you need to start thinking about your
trading account as a business.
So let's go over to the next video.
And Chris, after the next video, is
actually going to give you spreadsheet
classes, two spreadsheet classes on how to
manage your trading account as a business.
And I'll see you back at the desk towards
the end of the video series.
So let's go over to the next video series.